water is the source of life but we're
running out of it why is that these
pictures are from Chennai one of India's
largest cities
it didn't just wake up to dry tops
Chennai has been gradually losing water
because of two reasons low rainfall and
depletion of underground water
reservoirs male you may I'm adding in
the Gurukul male environment and easily
there were come on hang in there hang
our caste apart a great Aniki but how
did the city of 10 million get to this
point after 1990s because of the
globalization of the economy the Indian
economy also expanded very rapidly to
cope up with such a rapid growth
especially in the urban centers of India
we started building up the cities in an
unmanaged and unplanned fashion in that
process we somehow neglected water site
or the resource management side or Fox
it is growth so China is the first
problem is unregulated urbanization in
fact Anna University researchers say it
has lost one third of its wetlands in
the last decade due to development
projects and that loss is now causing
schools hotels and other businesses to
close down nationally Mitanni Turin
Sultanate in useless or nano
coordination can occur in two packets
and ninamarie token gotta go to karana
then Topanga dani.bora family happily
passed on all the vitalife a minister's
name is Lanna the mary pitama obtained a
macaroni party a the bridge eggomatic
chennai is not the only indian city with
this problem 21 major cities in india
including the capital Delhi could run
out of water as early as next year
that's according to the national
institution for transforming India
another report says that nearly half of
the Indian population is going to see an
extreme of water shortage very soon but
is this a result of for water management
we get very good amount
of precipitation in the form of rainfall
as well as snowfall the challenge is
that we capture around 8% of that
precipitation today I have which is a
significantly lags behind some of the
global based average so how does this
crisis look worldwide according to a
study published in 2014 one in four of
the world's big cities are water
stressed in 2015 the situation in Brazil
Sao Paulo was so bad that police had to
escort water trucks to avoid looting the
city had less than twenty days worth of
water
more recently in 2018 South African
officials announced that Cape Town
residents would run out of water in
three months this of course led to water
rationing one-fourth of the city's
population lives in informal settlements
this complicated the situation as these
areas have no regular supply of water
there are always pictures of you know
running taps and broken fixtures and
look at the leakage and all erase but
the reality is that those those 1
million people out of a population of
four only use four and a half percent of
the water climate change is altering
weather patterns and water supplies
around the world why does this matter
because even though 70% of the earth's
surface is covered by water only 3% is
considered consumable fresh water which
means the water shortage crisis is not
just an Asian or African problem
according to the World Health
Organization 2.1 billion people lack
safe drinking water the main issue is
that demand for water all types of water
for different uses particularly for
agriculture or urban development or
industrialization demand for water is
skyrocketing the second problem is that
water is not distributed evenly around
the earth where we want the water is
often where it is not but it's getting
more expensive to transport water from
where it is what abundant to where it's
needed the most according to a United
Nations report the lack of fresh water
is a major factor in conflict areas such
as Syria and money in fact the World
Resources Institute says that the
importance of water means that it can be
weaponized in his book the water paradox
professor Edward bobbya mentions the
economic importance of the crisis water
is more valuable in the sense that it
meets more needs even more than than
fossil fuels and oil and yet we've
treated it as if it's a free commodity
and that it will always be available in
supply but when you want to manage a
problem of scarcity you must think about
the fact that scarcity means something
means costs we must start by covering
the cost of providing better water and
sanitation services to ordinary people
better water supplies to certain
companies and for commercial uses we
need to do better when it comes to water
management and in saving rainwater
because if we don't and with a growing
global population the crisis will only
get bigger it's important that it cannot
be done just by policy or regulation of
course they do play a big role in
mandating some of the implementation but
but also a behavioural change of the
civil society Oh countries are facing
the same problem in parts of their
regions where you have got the shortage
and we need to start thinking of common
solutions and common approaches and
sharing examples of good management
practices that work in one part of the
world and that can be transferred to
others unless leadership around the
world acknowledges water shortage as a
problem cities will expand without
proper planning and water sources will
continue to be strained
what's your view on the water crisis how
can we solve it share your thoughts and
ideas in the comment section below until
next time goodbye
[Music]